[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now both very mutants life never I
believe the one getting one longer
commitment can be eaten not knocking
woman of our barrack remaining Billy
value
involuntary man of ability good job
became gangrenous back as indigenous
people living in the forests of the
Congo Basin they know so much about the
forest about the animals they can tell
you which animal especially in the last
two days and which direction it too
and they're real scientists in the
forest just watch it fill you up on the
capacity get take Abubakar take me in do
awesome that's gonna do boo boo okay
back ticket Moroccan lamb they cannot
bring Ricky I know a Bunga no wonder
people profit from the knowledge of the
environment and the forest in which they
live which will get them to do all sorts
of things for them because of the skills
they be contacted to kill elephants to
kill them
the animals in the bush and bring it out
and sell very cheap increasingly the
backers are getting involved in protein
and not because they are pushing for
themselves because they are pushing for
some big somebody who is coming to give
them small money or to pay them tokens
the backers are increasingly being used
because they are really poor sometimes
it has a packet of cigarette to get an
ivory
come baboon Key Club meeting with mr.
formula tech one day and double mechana
bamboo moving sunset forever world man
women are a confirmed walkie-talkie
welcome everyone has a blue car boom
boom boom boom even beam so far on there
for a repeat offender
I've got some backers are concerned
about what is happening to the
environment most of them are working
with us in the conservation side we have
backers as a game gasps echo God they
they are really very good
[Music]
hakuna cause probably kanakam barakaatuh
ciénaga Cassiano BBQ not well
move over to a little fool a balloon
Kakaako wall at Oracle when we look in
on our Benoit military
so one Rwanda movement beyond our garden
the under community we needed a story
idea for mojo Papa allowing the money is
given to Joe for wardrobe you can also
boombox
Ryota Swannanoa area then habla
geography wha
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]